now when tucker carlson said that we
should be calling the police or child
protective services
any time a child is wearing a mask
because that parent is committing child
abuse
something struck me and no it wasn't
exactly the
complete lunacy and insanity of the
statement that was clearly just designed
to trigger the libs
and to get people to rage watch tucker
carlson it was that
there was a decent chance that tucker
carlson was asking people to commit an
actual crime in the name of this stupid
mass-related culture war
[Music]
sponsored by curiosity stream and nebula
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because if you do what tucker
carlson says
well there's a decent chance you might
go to jail
if you haven't been following along
tucker carlson the ostensible hater of
big government and champion of personal
freedom
has suddenly found darn good reason why
the big government should interfere with
your personal freedom specifically
your right to raise your children the
way that you want to
remember this is the party of family
values
so what is this emergency that justifies
swift governmental action
human trafficking terrorism well no it's
actually something much more sinister
it's children
wearing cloth masks
[Music]
the next time you see someone in a mask
on the sidewalk or on the bike path do
not hesitate
ask politely but firmly would you please
take off your mask
science shows there is no reason for you
to be wearing it your mask
is making me uncomfortable oh yes the
libertarian wants people to stop doing
something that doesn't affect other
people in any way whatsoever
masks are for the guilty their
signifiers of shame and
submission and the guy who ostensibly
says that he wants the government to
leave him alone
included a rant that recommended that
his viewers call the cops if they see a
child outside
wearing a mask call the police
immediately contact child protective
services
keep calling until someone arrives yes
apparently parents everywhere are
committing
mass child abuse like these people and
these people and these people yes these
people are all
monsters committing child abuse and they
must be stopped because
here's the thing putting aside the legal
repercussions of calling the cps or
the police which we'll get to in just a
second as we've seen time and time again
in the news
anytime the police are called for
anything it has the possibility of
turning violent if not lethal for better
worse the police
are armed and any law whether it is
passing off a fake 20 bill or trying to
sell cigarettes without the correct
certificate has the possibility of being
enforced at the barrel
of a gun and of course the real civil
libertarians not
tucker carlson have recognized that the
preponderance of laws in this country
it may not happen very often but have
the possibility of being enforced by
people with guns and things can turn
south do not
call the police unnecessarily so the
point that i think tucker is trying to
make here
is that he doesn't agree with mass
mandates that require people and
children to wear
masks outdoors because outdoor
transmission is low
and the added benefit from wearing a
mask is
negligible because the transmission of
covid outdoors is just
low to begin with and fine that's very
probably true
but when people are being faced with a
global pandemic where
now over 500 000 americans have died
it's probably okay for people to freak
out a little bit and it's a false
equivalency to say that even if there
were no
outdoor transmission whatsoever that
there's no reason for a mask mandate
it's not the same thing to say that the
only reason for an outdoor mask mandate
might be to prevent outdoor transmission
for example maybe wearing a mask
outdoors makes it more likely that
you'll wear one
indoors maybe it guarantees that you'll
have a mask on your person when you
decide to
walk indoors maybe it normalizes the
idea of wearing masks in general after
all
these are the same people that made
wearing a mask full stop a cultural
issue
and of course when we talk about laws
like these they undergo rational basis
review so as long as there is
some rational reason for these laws
that makes the laws constitutional and
there are probably lots of other reasons
apart from stopping
outdoor transmission and i think even at
this point tucker isn't arguing against
wearing masks indoors until
everyone is vaccinated and then there is
another logical fallacy of false
equivalency where tucker is conflating
the idea that even if there's no reason
to wear mask outdoors at it being
actual child abuse to make children wear
masks
outdoors that is not the case we'll talk
about that more in just a second
and sure some of this reads as giving
people their own medicine
to the extent that he's saying that
people who were freaked out about a
deadly global pandemic
and they understandably wanted other
people to wear masks
but the risks were always asymmetric not
wearing a mask
endangered other people in a way that
wearing a mask simply
doesn't and never did but look it's
possible that he is simply satirically
saying that people should call the cops
and child protective services when they
see children outdoors wearing masks
honestly i can't tell at this point i
don't even know if tucker carlson
himself
is satire or not and i can't tell if his
recommendation
is satirical but honestly it sounds
genuine enough to at least talk about
whether this recommendation is illegal
or not so
either way let's have some fun with this
idiocy but let's delve into what would
happen if one of tucker carlson's
viewers
actually called child protective
services or the cops on parenting for
putting basks
on children now generally speaking in
america parents have the right to decide
matters involving their children's
health welfare and education although
the state will step in when there is
abuse neglect or mistreatment
parents have the right to decide what
their children listen to where they go
to church where they go to school what
they
wear and the medical care that they
receive and tucker carlson is on board
with this mostly he believes it is
authoritarian for the state to require
children to be vaccinated but
not authoritarian for the state to
investigate parents whose children
appear
in public with masks now tucker is
correct that states are empowered to
investigate reports of abuse and neglect
society is
rightfully concerned about children's
welfare and federal and state laws
require some professionals who actually
mandatorily report if they suspect abuse
these are known as
mandatory reporters and they include
people like doctors
social workers and teachers and since
we're talking about the substance of
these reports
let's address the elephant in the room
no making your children wear masks
is not child abuse no more so than
making your child wear
a hat or a sweater and look given the
number of scratchy wool sweaters that my
parents made me wear when i was young i
can understand why people wouldn't want
to do it
but it doesn't rise to the level of
child abuse
so i feel extremely confident in saying
that making your children wear masks
outdoors is
not child abuse parents can force their
kids to do a lot of things that have no
scientific basis
making them do things is not child abuse
for example if a child doesn't want to
go trick-or-treating
a parent could force them to go
trick-or-treating and
gasp wear a mask that's not
child abuse parents don't need a genuine
scientific basis for everything that
they make
their kids do parents can force their
kids to wash behind their ears with no
scientific basis whether that's helpful
or not they can
force kids to eat carrots even though
there's no scientific basis that it will
help their eyesight
and they can tell kids to turn off the
dome light in the car even though that's
definitively not illegal as i proved in
my other video
kids don't like doing lots of things
that they're forced to do often because
kids are really dumb and parents are not
committing child abuse just because
they're making kids do something that
they might not have
all of the scientific rationale for and
the same
is obviously true for masks as well if
you think that masks appreciably change
your oxygen levels
or have some other deleterious effects
may i recommend the channel medlife
crisis run by
my friend dr rohan francis or the dr
mike channel run by
dr mike who will disabuse you of the
notion that wearing a mask could
possibly
lead to child abuse but you already knew
that though on the other hand
scratchy wool sweaters that's going to
have to be the subject for
another video but let's talk about
mandatory reporting in 1974 the u.s
enacted the child abuse prevention and
treatment act
which requires all states to add
provisions to their laws that protect
mandatory reporters
from legal retaliation for making a
report this legal protection is called
immunity and without immunity a
mandatory reporter could be sued if the
report was not substantiated after the
investigation
the law recognizes that in some
situations the mandatory reporter might
not be sure about whether a child is
being abused or neglected therefore
in most jurisdictions mandatory
reporters are protected by immunity as
long as the report was made in good
faith if that's true they can't be sued
or prosecuted
in at least 15 states in the district of
columbia the presumption of good faith
applies to everyone not just mandatory
reporters so
if joe schmoe watched tucker carlson and
got the idea to call cps because
his neighbor's child was outside oh no
wearing a mask
there would be a presumption that the
person acted in good faith but that's
only in 15 states and that's only a
presumption an aggrieved parent
might be able to overcome that
presumption the unfortunate reality is
that sometimes people do make false
reports of abuse and neglect and that's
why there are laws making it illegal to
file
false reports of child abuse
mistreatment or neglect the logic behind
these laws is that any time a false
report comes in
it detracts from the time and resources
investigators could have to pursue real
cases of child abuse and neglect
and at least 29 states in puerto rico
penalize any person who willfully or
intentionally makes a false report of
child abuse or neglect
19 states and the virgin islands
classify false reporting as a
misdemeanor or similar charge
in florida illinois tennessee and texas
making a false report of abuse or
neglect is a felony and in other states
subsequent offenses are upgraded to
felonies now california maine minnesota
montana and nebraska don't impose
criminal penalties for false reports
instead they strip legal immunity from
people who make false claims
this means that individuals could face
criminal penalties for filing false
police reports perjuring themselves or
being sued for damages and that means
the karens and tuckers of the world who
make false cps reports
could face some serious sanctions so
what would qualify as
a false report and is that what tucker
is asking his audience to do
well an unfounded or unsubstantiated
report is not the same thing
as a false report so would the scenario
that tucker carlson outlined
actually be considered a false report
under the law well generally the legal
standard for determining whether report
is actually false is
knowingly and willfully this definition
comes from pennsylvania law and is
fairly common this generally means that
the person must be acting
in bad faith they must have known or
knew it was likely that the report was
false
eric wemple of the washington post
contacted child service departments in
several states and asked
whether the states could investigate a
tucker report for abuse and neglect
minnesota said wearing a mask or not
does not rise to the level of abuse or
neglect
new jersey said that the wearing or not
wearing of a mask whether inside or
outside is not by itself considered
abusive
and nevada had a forceful statement
explaining why this kind of call could
do actual damage
quote in no circumstance would a child
wearing a mask in public to reduce or
prevent the spread of disease
meet nevada's definition of abuse or
neglect of a child pursuant to nrs432b
the state's child welfare agencies have
limited resources to address real issues
of abuse and neglect
and if nevada does see a surge of
nonsense calls children in threat of
actual harm
will be in increased danger and that's
just to child protective services
filing a false police report is an
example of speech that is not protected
by the first amendment to prove that a
person committed this crime the
prosecutor generally has to show first
that the
defendant filed a report with an
investigative agency like a police
department the local district attorney
state attorney general or cps and second
that the defendant knew or had reason to
believe that the report was
false in some jurisdictions the
prosecutor must also prove that the
defendant made the false statement with
the intent to interfere with the
criminal justice system in virginia for
instance the prosecutor has to show that
the caller intended to mislead or
interfere with the operation of a law
enforcement agency and on top of that
some states have passed
so-called anti-karen laws to address the
raft of spurious 9-1-1 calls that have
been made for example
after a new yorker named amy cooper
called 9-1-1 to report a black man was
threatening her because
he asked her to leech her dog in central
park the meme became a movement to hold
people accountable for making false
9-1-1 calls now
some cities and states are passing laws
to stop these karen's from wasting
everyone's time and
after the cooper incident virginia was
one of the states who added anti-karen
legislation
the virginia code prohibiting false
police reports was amended to make
filing a false report a class six felony
if the report was motivated by
discrimination quote if a person
intentionally gives a false report as to
the commission of any crime to any law
enforcement official
causes another to give a false report to
any law enforcement official or
calls or summons any law enforcement
official against another person
because of his race religious conviction
gender disability gender identity sexual
orientation color
or national origin the person is guilty
of a class six felony in addition to new
harsher criminal
penalties cities like san francisco have
approved legislation to give people who
were targets of vacaron
the right to sue the caller and this of
course makes tucker carlson
the biggest karen of them all call the
police immediately
though in fairness to tucker carlson at
least in this particular instance
these calls don't seem to be motivated
by discrimination
rather just an incredibly misguided
right-wing culture war
and these are just the statutory
criminal issues a criminal issue needs
to be brought by the state the district
attorney
usually then there's also the
possibility that a victim of
these reports could just simply sue the
person for civil damages related to the
actions
and a parent could bring a lawsuit for
something called intentional infliction
of emotional distress against a person
who makes
a false report iied is a tort claim that
focuses on intentional conduct resulting
in extreme emotional distress
which causes a mental reaction such as
anguish grief or fright
to prove a claim for ied a plaintiff has
to establish four elements one that the
defendant acted intentionally and
recklessly
the defendant's conduct was extreme and
outrageous the defense act is the cause
of the distress
and the plaintiff suffers severe
emotional distress as a result of the
defendant's conduct though in fairness
it can be incredibly difficult to make
an iid claim
some legal commentators go so far as to
call this the civil equivalent of
a rico prosecution because it's just
never rico
but it's difficult for a plaintiff to
prove that conduct was so extreme or
outrageous that it caused severe anguish
resulting in recoverable damages though
a plaintiff would probably say that this
is the equivalent of
getting swatted where there's the real
possibility
of injury or death and no one likes
having the police called for
something as ridiculous as wearing a
mask
so under some circumstances someone
might be able to make a civil case for
ied related to one of these calls but if
you tried to make a case against someone
making a tucker report it's not going to
be a slam dunk because there's going to
be
many defenses available the first of
which is that there's a difference
between making up a complete lie about
something that never factually happened
and calling child protective services
because of something that did actually
happened that you
mistakenly believe gives rise to
something called
child abuse and so the main defense to
any of these charges would be that the
person who reported the masks
had a good faith belief that they were
witnessing something that was concerning
after all
they saw it on tv that if a child is
wearing a mask it must be
child abuse that's the thing about good
faith beliefs is that
the person might be a complete nut case
but if they subjectively believe that to
be the case they might be operating
in good faith if they said they feared
the child couldn't breathe or was having
an asthma attack
or had facts to back up their assertion
that the child's health was compromised
maybe the report could be legitimate and
it would be incredibly difficult for
someone to prove that the person who was
making the tucker report
was doing it out of spite or doing it to
intentionally harm
the parents of the children that were
wearing masks but on the other hand
tucker is making such a facially
ridiculous objectively unreasonable
argument that maybe it's
not possible for someone to have an
actual good faith subjective belief
under these circumstances
clearly wearing a mask doesn't rise to
the level of child abuse
no more than wearing a scarf or a hat or
a mask when you're trick-or-treating
would be child abuse and if we're
talking about
the message that it's sending are we
saying that the entire continent of
asia is committing child abuse when
people are wearing masks even in
non-pandemic times
or that maybe since it doesn't actually
harm the people that are wearing masks
they want to send a message
at the end of the day it's a decision
that doesn't harm anyone
including the children and it's a
decision that's up to the parents
i don't know man it seems like after
this whole pandemic thing we should be
bending over backwards to help parents
rather than
calling the cops on them at the end of
the day
i guess even if you did make a tucker
report
you'd have a hard time making out a
criminal or civil case but
there's likely to be a small subsection
of tucker watchers that if they follow
through with his advice
they might be subject to criminal or
civil penalties
and i guess if there's one thing that we
can all agree on it's that
you probably should never do what tucker
carlson tells you to do
now i have some other choice words for
tucker carlson over on the extended
version of this video that i posted to
nebula
you know it's funny that i did an entire
video on tucker carlson without
actually mentioning the tucker carlson
defense which you can now get with a
huge discount when you get it with
curiosity stream because sometimes
talking about the insane things that
tucker carlson does is too hot for
youtube
which is why my creator friends and i
teamed up to build our own platform
where
creators don't need to worry about
demonetization or the dreaded algorithm
it's called nebula and we're thrilled to
be partnering with curiositystream not
only are my nebula versions ad free and
extended but they're also released early
before the youtube versions because
nebula is a place where we can
experiment with content and
put things that we couldn't put on
youtube and it features lots of
youtube's
top educational-ish creators like mkbhd
lindsay ellis and polyphonic and we're
thrilled to be partnering with curiosity
stream because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries and long-form
educational content on the internet and
now they have an entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries and crime if you
like my videos you will love the stuff
on curiosity stream and we worked out a
deal where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with a link in the description
you'll also get a nebula subscription
for free and to be clear
that nebulous subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member
and right now curiosity stream is
offering 26 off of their annual plans
that's less than
15 for the entire year for both
curiosity stream and nebula
so if you click the link in the
description you'll get both curiosity
stream and nebula for 26
off or you can go to curiositystream.com
legaleagle it's a great way to support
this channel and educational content
directly for under 15
per year so just click on the link in
the description plus clicking on that
link really helps out this channel
so do you agree with my analysis are you
going to be making a tucker report when
you see a child wearing a mask
leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews
about
the legal issues in the news so just
click on this playlist or i'll see you
in court